today chicago's vaccine mandate takes
effect but in a city surging with
violent crime what does this mean for
the men and women who keep it all safe
john katzenzara is the president of the
chicago fraternity of police and he
joins us now good morning to you john
good morning ainsley good morning so she
says this is your option you either get
you can get vaccinated or you can file
for an exemption if you do that and
choose not to get vaccinated then you
have to get tested twice a week why are
you against that
well because the policy for first of all
is schizophrenic
the teachers have a different policy the
teachers are literally you're vaccinated
or you get tested you don't have to
report your vaccine status we have a
mandate to report our vaccine status by
midnight tonight doesn't make any sense
so that's step one you're asking people
not to go on the city's portal and
report whether or not they've been
vaccinated or not
correct okay so what do your police
officers say how many of them are
vaccinated or choosing not to
the numbers we have are probably around
half are not
but even the ones that are still like
myself believe that a forced mandate is
absolutely wrong well you have a good
argument why are they making t why are
they making police officers report their
vaccination status and not teachers what
is her her response to that
don't worry about it don't look over
there listen to what i say everything
from this mayor is a dictatorship this
is all about policy from the top there
was no public outcry for this policy to
take effect she just decided she was
going to do it and pushing on the entire
city workforce across the board
there's low cooperation and this is just
not the police department you include
firemen first responders we've gotten
calls from laborers union streets and
sand the water department you name it
everybody across the board is up in arms
about this mandate but it doesn't matter
she said no one's going to be sent home
immediately it's going to take a few
days for them to figure out who is and
is not complying she says but if you
don't agree to take the vaccine or get
tested twice a week
we will move forward and put people on a
no pay status how will your officers pay
their bills
well i guess we're going to see how that
works out because we had a meeting the
other night and
our lodge had never been more filled
with members it's
they are literally engaged in this fight
going forward they were willing to go
into a no pay status at midnight tonight
and get sent home
if that's what was going to happen and
get locked out by the city i don't know
that that's going to change very much if
now they're threatening suspension or
even termination you know the reality is
we have a profession nobody else wants
to do right now they cannot get anybody
to go into this a police academy but yet
here she is vilifying the police yet
again in a city that has over 185
expressway shootings this year alone
over 280 kids shot this year alone and
she acts like there's nothing else going
on but this covid and i hear there are a
thousand police vacancies in chicago
crime is is surging and so are homicides
thank you for everything you did and for
working through the pandemic john
thanks ainsley you're welcome we did
reach out to mayor lightfoot's office
for comment but we did not hear back i'm
steve ducey i'm brian kill me and i'm
ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis